سنتابع قضيه الطلاق المليار يورو هل حصل
هذا الطلاق او لم يحصل كنا سنستضيف العريس
اليوم لكنه اعتذر عن الحضور في اللحظه
الاخيره ولاسباب مجهوله وهذا الاعتذار
يزيد من الضبابيه حول القضيه لكن الجدل
مستمر وهو عن مساله المؤخر حيدر وغدير لم
يرد على الاتهامات لكن الشعب العراقي
اكتفى بالاعلان عبر حسابه ان الانفصال
الودي كان لعدم الانسجام والتوافق
من الاردن والعراق سالنا السيدات ما هو
المؤخر الذي ترينه مناسبا في عقد الزواج
نتابع
امامي للسيد حيدر الخالد محمود
والانسه غدير فيصل الفهد من مواليد اربعه
خمسه وتسعين وتم عقد الزواج بينهم على
كتاب الله وسنه رسوله صلى الله عليه وسلم
وعلى نهر مقدم واحد كيلو دال
عيار 21 ومهر مؤخر مقداره مليار
هلا انا بشوف المناسب كمؤخر يكون رينج
تقريبا اقل شيء 10,000 دينار عشان بزمن
هذا السنه هيك يعني متهورين ويعني جيل
طايش فشوي هيك يمكن المبالغ الماليه
تمسكنا يعني انه نفس هذه العلاقات الزوجيه
فبحس عشره الاف مناسب عشره علشان شويه
ظروف بالاردن مو كثير تمام عشان تخفف عن
الطلاق يعني عشان ما يصير فيه طلاق كثير
في الاردن المؤخر المناسب عشره الاف انا
بقول يعني هيك لجميع الفئات مشان هو ضمان
بس للصبايا لانه كتير كتير ولا قليل ان
شاء الله مناسب جدا 10,000 بهالايام هاي
لازم عشره متاخر عشان ضمان للبنات وكمان
لازم الرحمه ما يغلي اكثر الواحد مشان
هالايام اللي احنا فيها هلا المؤخر يعني
الطبيعي عنا من ثلاثه لخمسه لانه يعني ما
بدنا نطير بالارقام بنظلم الشباب هلا
المقدم خمسه يعني اللي بيقدروا عليه طبعا
هالايام صار ثلاثه وانا عادي ما عندي
مشكله بثلاثه المؤخر يعني خمسه معقول هلا
احنا صح بدنا نضمن حق البنت بس مش نطير
كمان بالارقام بدنا نراعي ظروف الشباب
وانا مع الشباب يعني
يعني انا عن تجربتي عن نفسي اني قبل ثمان
سنوات يعني تزوجت والحمد لله
فاتذكر يعني بوقتها انه من جوده يسالون
ابويا انه شقد تطلب مهر على بنتك وايد حكي
حكايه كلش حلوه قال لهم بنتي فلوس الدنيا
كلها ما تغني اصفر من اظفرها يعني عشره
بعشره هو براحته وبقناعتي بس اني اشوف
المناسبه اشرب عشره
[موسيقى]
التمسوا ولو بخاتم من فضله يعني القصد هو
بالبدايه المهر بصوره اساسيه لغه واصلا هو
يعني معطاء هديه للمراه فيعني ممكن تحديد
قيمه ماديه او معنويا فالمبالغه بالمهر
راح يعيق من الزواج هلا انا بفضي لما اقدم
كتاب قران والمؤخر
ته الانسان بيدفع شو بيدفع وما في مشكله
بقى الناس حسب اوضاعها ما فيك تجبرها باي
شيء
[موسيقى]
شو حلو اجوبه مختلفه عجبني جواب الاردن
قبل شوي في صبيه قالت مش مهم الارقام
المهم انه نساعد الشباب بدهم يتجوز
هالايام يكون انه هذا اهم طيب سمر انت اذا
سالتك عن مؤخرك قديه انا مقدمه مؤخره كان
دينار اردني لان تزوجت بالاردن ومؤخر
دينار اردني لانه والدي مثل ما قالت الاخت
عنده مبدا انه اذا بنتي مو مرتاحه مع
زوجها اني انطيه فلوس حتى يعني تطلع من
هاي العلاقه بس للاسف مو دائما يعني الحمد
لله اني متزوجه ومرتاحه بس هذه هذا ايضا
يمكن كان اعتبره يعني مو غلط بس يعني كان
قرار عاطفي وليس عقلاني لانه للاسف
القانون في بلاده مو مثل
بامريكا واوروبا يعطي 50% للمراه المراه
اذا تركت عملها وتركت الوظيفتها وقعدت
تربي الاولاد وتدير بالها على البيت
وبعدين تصير مشكله بعد عشره عشرين سنه ايش
راح تساوي من وين تصرف انا اشتغلت فتره مع
مطلقات وكانت هذه الرئيسيه انه يعذبها
يعني فوق ما هو خاينها يتركها بدون مصروف
بدون مصاري وخلص اولادها كبروا وهي غير
حاضنه وما في اي شيء يضمن حقها غير هذا
المؤخر اللي حتى لو اخذتها بالبدايه الالف
دولار قبل عشرين سنه ما الها قيمه مثل ما
هسه فلازم يكون في قانون قوانين تحميل
المراه اكثر بهذا المجال خصوصا انه ما
تضمن الشخص اللي امامك انت يعني بالنهايه
نحكي عن الغيره النسائيه ما غيرتي من بعض
الفتيات او الذين تزوجوا مهر عالي
ومؤخرة بالع
باللي بقرار والدي